はぁ…。
こんにちわ…
疲労系Youtuber、はじめしゃちょーです…。
あのねぇ～…しょぉーじき言いますよ。
僕はその見栄とか張りませんから。
正直に言って…
忙しいです。
大学、卒論、カードゲーム（?）、テレビゲーム（?）、スマホゲーム（?）、Youtube。
俺にはやらない（やらなきゃいけない）ことがたぁーっくさんあってねぇ
もぉほんっとにねぇーあのー冗談抜きで忙しいんですよ。
1日っていうのはね24時間で構成されてまして、
人はその24時間以内でなにができるかってことを考えてしっかりうごかなきゃいけない
だがしかし僕はその24時間では足りないぐらい色んなことをやらなきゃいけないんですよ
なので僕の生活リズムはもうめちゃくちゃです!
24時間というこの一つの時間を軽くね一周半ぐらいオーバーしてしまうことはよくあるんで
僕の生活リズムはめちゃくちゃで、
昼夜逆転してるんです今。
なのでね…もうなんかー…そのー…
布団にいく時がなんか朝とか、
起きたら夜だったとか、
すごいこうねなんか心が悲しいときがあるんすよ（´・ω・｀）
うおぅぉぅぅぅ（泣）
授業とかの予定もあるしね
朝に寝たのにすぐ起きなきゃいけないとかいって
僕はもう睡眠不足のときも多い。
もおぉぉぉぉぉぉぉぉぉぉ（嘆き）
I・YA・DA!
はい。
隠さず言ってしまいました
なかなか忙しいこんな僕なんですけども、
こんな僕に!
とんでもないものが届きました!
こちらです!
うおっ!
思ったより大きい!
はい!そのためちょっと疲労困憊しているこの僕にね
ベルメゾンさんからこんなものが届きましたああああ!
えっ、すごっ!
まってまずとりあえず枕がついてんの?
枕がついてる↓
おおすごい、これもくっついてんのか!
えー、うたた寝クッションというものでございます!
こちら、なにがすごいかと言いますと
まずこのビーズクッションがついている
プ・ラ・ス!
普通のクッションとこのビーズクッション合体しているという
でもこのままこう寝れるわけですよ。
あっ…
HA☆HA☆HA
こいつは寝れるわ。
えこれ枕とか置いていいってこと?
これじゃ枕もこうしたらもこうこのまま寝れるってことじゃん
あー寝れるわ
これはやばいぞ!
これはまた人をダメにするな。
これはまた人をダメにするでございます（2回目）
こちら素材のほうなんですけども、
リバーシブルになっていて
こっちはこの…さらさら系、夏とかはこっちなんです
さらさら系の方と、これバッとひっくり返すと
こちらのね、冬などには温かいであろうもふもふのね、もふもふの生地の方がありまーす
もうこれだけでも僕はもう満足ですよ
オレね、ベェ↑ッドにいくのが最近めんどくさいんですよ
こゆね、クッションとしても使えますし
これでパソコンとかもうねスマホとかもできるし、
クッションあるあるですよ
クッションに座ってたら、ズルズルズルっていっちゃうやつ?
こっちのクッションとこのビーズクッション合体してるんで、
も（う）ここに乗っちゃえばズルズルいくことがないんすよ
よくこの二つを合体させようと思ったわけよ
究極のシェア割りだわ
ああああ～ん////
これはいいっすわぁー…
で!でね?オレはね、気付いてしまったんだ…
ここにあるこの、さっきまくらまくらつ（言）ってたんですけども、
ファ↑スナーがついてます!
ファスナーを開けると中には?
なぁ～んと、なぁ～んと!
毛布が付いてるわけですよお!
ここにチャックが付いてるんですけども、このチャックを
あーきたきたきた
つなげました
ここでつないじゃうと、もーそーいうことっすよね
もーそーいうことっすよね!（2回目）
わぁっ!もーそーいうことじゃん!
このまま、もう、おやすみじゃん
このまま寝れるわけですうぅ↑ぅぅ↓ぅぅ↓
やばいでしょこれ!!
いまのクッションは、ここまで進化したでございます。
このタイプのビーズクッションだけは持ってたんすよ
これでオレはもうね満足してた
さらに、それに!
通常のクッションが付いて、さ・ら・に!!
この寝袋も付いてるんで、もー…
このまま寝れるってわけですよ（和み）
やべ、卒論とか動画編集…
ああーっ、ああーっ…って言って、
ああっ…ああ↑っ…ああ↑っ
ってなったらそのままこうね、寝れるわけですよ
HAHAHAHA☆
いやほんとねいいよこれー、もー。
あのーネタじゃないほうで、ほんっとにおすすめです、うたた寝クッション!
このまま寝れるっていうのがもうなによりも幸せですから
睡眠は大事なんですけどもね
まあ、より良いその睡眠の質を上げるためにね
このやわらかいビーズクッション、
やわらかいクッション、
そして、やわらかい寝袋!
この3点セットが一つになっている、うたた寝クッション!
もしね、そのクッションでただ座るだけじゃなくて
クッションでそのまま寝ちまいたい!とか、
寒いから毛布が欲しーい!とか、
こういうちょっと欲張りな方は、ぜひ!
うたた寝クッション、おすすめで～す
じゃっ、おやすみなさぁ～い
はあ↑あっ!